for many years warehouses have been seen
as the least glamorous enter the
commercial property market behind the
likes of offices and shopping centers
but now their moment has come see grow
the UK's largest operator of warehouses
has just been elevated to the footsie
100 as e-commerce has boosted demand for
its sheds today reported at 23 percent
rise in half your pre-tax profits to 91
million pounds and david smith is the
chief executive he joins me now so David
is it's all down to e-commerce it's not
entirely down to e-commerce if you look
at our business we we have a very broad
range of customers across lots of
different industries I mean we touch
just about every part of the economy but
there's no doubt being that the the big
drive of demand at the moment and has
been for a little while is the growth in
internet retailing I mean you know the
names of the that a selling product
online are growing they need space for
delivery of the product and it's a you
know it's a bit of a boom market at the
moment for that type of property and you
don't see any sign of that drying up
anything any time in the near future I
think it's you know it's got a long way
to go in the UK which is a big part of
our business what we found interesting
in the last few months is that on the
continent we have a big part of our
portfolios in continental Europe as well
and there's been a noticeable
acceleration of the growth in e-commerce
on the continent and a lot of space
again being demanded by retailers online
and traditional retailers who want to be
able to have that offering the
interesting thing is though that your
rents are substantially lower in
continental Europe than they are in the
UK
yeah rents have always been a little bit
cheaper in continental Europe and that's
simply down to land prices I mean we're
in a very land constrained country in
the UK you know it's Mark Twain who said
buy land they're not making it anymore I
mean when it comes to warehouse space
it's actually shrinking you look at
somewhere like London you know former
industrial land is being handed over to
two other uses particularly residential
so the amount of space available for for
warehouses is shrinking at a time of
course when demand is growing because of
the internet growth and an increasing
population in the big cities also using
some of your warehouses so as data
centers is that more profitable than
their more traditional uses it's a
little bit more profitable the the great
thing about data centers it's been a
huge huge growth area for us I mean we
have something like 25 you
server farms if you like you know that
they look like warehouses from the
outside they're full of very
sophisticated expensive IT equipment and
with all the all the growth in in
YouTube and streaming and all the things
we do it's become a very much hot
property and we the thing we like about
them is that the the customers that take
that space they put a massive investment
in terms of equipment inside the
buildings and so they're likely to stay
there for a very long time now nearly
two-thirds of your assets are in London
and the South East of England lest we
forget you used to be called flour
States close proximity to Heathrow
Airport and worried I that this third
runways ever gonna get built well not
only do we have a lot of a lot of space
in Slough and the Thames Valley but we
have a lot of property in and around
London Airport London airports including
the cargo facilities at at Heathrow so
we're very interested in that we think
that there's a very strong case for the
third runway at Heathrow I mean it's our
only hub airport it's it's really
important in the context of bricks it
especially I would say that the UK can
reach out conform new trading
relationships and that means we need to
be able to get there quickly what a lot
of people don't realize with with cargo
and exports is a very large part by
value of UK exports something like 40
percent go by plane and they don't go in
separate planes just for cargo they go
in them in what's called the belly hole
the underbelly of passenger planes so
it's very it's a great way of accessing
new markets if we can put those new
routes on so the case for Heathrow I
would say is is stronger than it's ever
been and briefly David you worried about
a drop-off in cargo and freight volumes
post brexit they've been holding up very
well in fact you know that possibly
because of the the weaker sterling
exporters have had a pretty good time in
terms of their competitiveness alright
David Leath from Seagrove good to see
you thanks very much for joining